-Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that
we should post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have your voting
clickers at your seats?
Everyone got them?
All right, good, yeah.
So you can vote --
vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
-Ooh.
-You can only vote once
per tweet, though.
-Oh, so you can't
vote yes and no.
-That's -- That would be
counterintuitive.
-Well, I'm just --
-Yeah, so you would -- yes.
You can vote on every one
if you like.
-Is there any way to vote no
multiple times for one --
for the same tweet?
-No, that is --
You cannot do that, no.
-No -- No multiple thumbs down.
-No multiple thumbs down,
Tariq, no.
Whatever you choose
is locked in for that tweet.
-So then there'd be
no multiple thumbs up, either.
-Ah, see?
That's how they get you.
-You guys should go out
after the show.
[ Laughter ]
And just talk.
Higgins, you have yours?
-I got it, I got it.
-Roots, you got your clickers?
All right, whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we'll tweet it out live
on the show
so you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it from home.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, nice, nice.
-It's like a shared experience.
-Ooh, yeah.
-That's what it's all about,
bringing people together.
All right, here we go.
-Yes!
-The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I have a feeling that's
not gonna be the one.
But you know what...
-You know what?
You gotta stress them --
you gotta test them, right?
-It's something --
We're doing this together, so...
-Yeah.
-If I lose, we all lose.
-Yeah. So, uh, all right.
Everyone cast your votes?
You did?
Okay, all right.
Let's see. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah, okay, all right, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Oh, my gosh.
-It looked like
that women's logo.
-Oh, my gosh.
It almost looked like an
offensive logo, yeah.
-Wow.
-All right.
Well, I guess it's not that one.
All right,
how about this next one here?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I'm casting my vote, too.
-I'm gonna give that a yes.
-Yeah.
I like that one.
All right.
Cast your votes, everybody.
I'm getting some head shakes.
All right.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
-Oh, my gosh!
Didn't like that one, either.
Look, I don't know if they
get any better, folks.
-What if they don't like
any of them?
-I know, that's very possible.
That's very possible.
[ Chuckles ]
-I gave that one a yes.
-Here's number three.
Yeah, I call 'em garbanzos.
-Yeah, garbanzo it up.
-Only on the weekends,
though, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This one here says...
♪♪
All right, cast your vote.
It's a very honest audience.
They're telling us exactly
what they like and don't like.
Roots, you all cast your vote?
-Yep.
-All right, good.
Let's see the results
on that one.
Whoa!
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Garbanzo!
-That's a banger right there!
-Yeah!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Throw the others
in the garbage.
-I know, in the garbanzos beans
over there.
[ Laughter ]
All right, let's --
we have two more.
Here we go.
This one says...
[ Laughter ]
Everyone's trying it right now.
♪♪
All right, looks like everyone
voted quickly on that.
I go with the fastest --
-That was the fastest.
-Going by speed,
that was the fastest.
The audience was, like, "No."
-That's the one.
-"No, thank you."
-They -- really fast.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, they liked it!
-Oh!
♪♪
Wow!
-Wow.
-I was gonna say
"the 'nose' have it."
[ Audience groans ]
You know, like "no's,"
like plural of "no."
-You're right, you're right.
-But also, the nose --
-Save it for your --
-For my one-man show?
-Save it for
your Twitter account.
[ Laughter ]
Here's the last one, here.
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
It's a great name.
Great name -- staple remover.
-Great name for a band.
-Yeah.
All right.
I cast my vote.
You guys ready?
Let's see the results.
-Oh.
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
Little half and half.
-Interesting, interesting, yeah.
All right, guys.
Well, we have a winner
just by looking at the votes.
It is...
[ Drumroll ]
Tweet number three!
"The best people at saying 'no'
are DJs and McDonald's employees
when you ask
if the ice cream machine
is working."
Okay.
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
Thank you for helping out.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet,"
and enjoy it.